sherry what's the question you get asked
most often um I think everybody is
really curious about audience audience
building and crowdfunding I get a lot of
questions about you know usually after a
campaigns already launched which
sometimes is too late to be asking that
question often as well when you're
launching going about to launch your
film and then you start asking questions
about the audience that's totally
backwards that all these questions
really need to be started in the very
beginning of this you know when you're
making the film when you're writing the
script when you're thinking about it
there should be in your mind who who am
i writing for who do I imagine watching
this movie that I'm writing I would
think that would make it easier a little
bit in the process that you're you know
maybe putting in in jokes or you're
being sure to include a certain kind of
information because you know that's what
your audience is going to want to know
if you don't have that idea when you're
writing it continues to be a problem
throughout into distribution because
it's it remains vague you're not sure
who you're going after you're not sure
who's going to respond to this material
and it makes it that much harder because
you're putting all your time and your
effort in your money into this without a
clear idea of how you're going to get
anything out of it so you know that's
one of the big questions is audience and
the time to ask that is not we're in
post and now we're trying to figure it
out or we're about to raise money and
crowdfunding and we need to figure this
out it's when you're developing the idea
and to start with I ask who are you you
know what what are you interested in
what drew you to this story why do you
feel compelled to tell it then where do
you hang out online where do you hang
out offline what do you read who do you
listen to all those aspects to starting
with with you makes it lots easier
because you know yourself you know
that's not hard to identify its when
they start with these demographics 18 to
35 women you know
that's huge huge disparate group they
don't all love the same thing so
thinking more along the lines of
interest and psychology and what
emotionally moves it really takes you
then out of an age group you're really
targeting then an interest group a
psychology that you want to find and
it's much easier to find those people
then when you're just targeting a blank
page and once you do once you have
identified your audience and you're sort
of ready to take that next step what are
those next steps you know where do you
go from there well um I have sort of
changed my thoughts about when you
should start this process of audience
engagement one I think that artists
should be doing that all the time so in
that way you are creating your own
identity in marketing speak it would be
brand I find filmmakers don't like to
use that word but I mean in marketing
that is what it a brand is your identity
your personality so you should be
sharing that personality all the time
when you're online professionally I
don't mean what are you having for
breakfast where you went on vacation
with your family you know deep dark
secrets about yourself I don't mean to
make all your private thoughts known and
your privacy given up but from a
professional standpoint what drives you
what motivates you and and start you can
start today you know was sharing that a
figuring of pulling people toward you
who are of that same mindset who are
compelled by the same thing you're
compelled with a great book that I read
over Christmas was called start with why
it's by simon Sinek and he says people
don't buy what you do they buy why you
do it so you should always be showing
people your why you know you should
always start from thinking how does this
show why I do what I do and those same
people who are compelled to do to think
that way or do those things or are
motivated by the same things that you
are get drawn to you now if you're a
negative person and I've seen this
happen a lot online where people are
very cutting and they cut
people down and they always have really
negative things to say and then they get
surprised when negativity starts coming
back at them you know on their sites in
their comments on their blogs on their
Facebook page lots of negative comments
it's what what you're putting out in the
world is what is coming back into you
what's attracted to you so if you don't
want that then don't be that don't show
that of yourself online but so that's
what you start to begin with now if you
have a project during the time when
you're in production when you're writing
in your in production your your
stockpiling you're collecting you're
looking for all the assets that you're
going to be able to use or that you can
use to create more material for later
but hold off on the online engagement
opening up your social channels till
you're about six months from your
premiere because in six months you can
keep the motivation up you can keep the
momentum you can release new things and
six months is not a terrible burden and
the audience can stay with you for that
long if you're two years or three years
to making a film you're not going to be
able to keep up that project specific
content release for very long it's just
it will be too draining for you you'll
run out of ideas and the audience will
get bored you know they when is this
thing happening when is this thing
coming out they kind of do expect that
when they hear about it it's soon going
to be replaced and they'll be able to
see it so they can wait about six months
or about four months but they can't wait
for indefinite period of time so when
you're thinking about ProjectWise for a
long time you're going to be collecting
and thinking about how you're going to
release and then when you get into post
and when you see okay we're about six
months from women doesn't have to be a
firm date you know you don't have to
know if you're doing it from a festival
you won't know if you're gonna get in
but you know around October around
january it'll be ready and we will be
looking to have the premiere then get
started then start showing your your
project off
getting an interest and getting people
then you're maintaining your pages and
you're cultivating an audience for the
project
you